okay hey everyone so welcome to the
final week of the class um what I want
to do today is share with you a few
generalizations of reinforcement
learning and of mdps so you've learned
about the basic MVP formula zone of
states action stations info releases
compactor and rewards the first thing
you see today is to you know slight
generalizations of this framework to
state action rewards and to find the
horizon MVPs that make it a little bit
easier for you to model certain types of
problems certain types of robots or
certain types of factory automation
problems will be easier to model with
these two small generalizations so talk
about those first and then second we'll
talk about linear dynamical systems last
Wednesday you saw a fitted value
iteration which was a way to solve for
an MDP even when the state space may be
infinite even when the state space is
several numbers was RN so it's an
infinite list of states or contingency
other states we use fitted value
iteration in which we're to use a
functional approximator right like
linear regression to try to approximate
the value function there's one very
important special case of an MDP where
even if the state space is infinite of
continuous real numbers does that well
there's one important special case we
can still compute the value function
exactly without needing to use you know
like a linear function approximate or to
use something like linear regression in
the inner loop a fitted value iteration
and so you also see that today and when
you can take a robot or some factory
automation tools or whatever problem and
model within this framework it turns out
to be incredibly efficient because you
can fit a continuous for the value
function as a function of the states
without needing to approximate you can
just compute the exact value function
even though the state space is
continuous so this is a framework that
doesn't apply to all problems but when
it does apply is incredibly convenient
gruffly efficient so you see that in a
second half of today oh yes a 1:1
tactical oh two two tactical things um
let's see from the questions that we're
getting from students um since they're
asking us oh how is grading and CSU's
you know and whatever I did well and
does you know didn't do so on that um
for people taking a class pass/fail c-
or better as a passing great this is
quite I think there's a standard at
Stanford and I think sisters mignon has
historically been one of the heavy
workload classes we know that people
taking sis you know I yeah I see a few
has nothing people King sisters end up
you know putting a lot of work on this
class maybe frankly more than average
for even Stanford courses and so we've
usually been quite nice with respect to
party and acknowledge that so I think
yeah just for what as well so don't
don't don't sweat too much do work hard
for the finer projects don't don't sweat
too much um oh and on Wednesday after
Claus had a funny question after I
talked about the fitted value iteration
question the Sun came out to me and said
hey Andrew um you know this algorithm
you you just told us does it actually
work it doesn't actually work on the
Tongass helicopter and the answer is yes
the algorithms are teaching you know if
you do fits evaluation as you learned
last week it will work on flying an
autonomous helicopter at low speed so
your fly very high speeds very dynamic
maneuvers crazy bang flipping upside
down you need a bit more than that but
for flying a helicopter at low speeds
the the exact algorithm that you learned
last Wednesday as well as any of the
algorithms you learned today including
them lqr you know if you actually ever
need to find autonomous helicopter
forever all these albums were actually
work decently well work quite well for
flying helicopter at low speeds maybe
not at very very high speeds and a crazy
dynamic maneuvers but those speeds these
algorithms
pretty much as I'm presenting them won't
work so okay
so the first generalization to the MDP
framework that I want to describe is
state action rewards and so so far we've
had the rewards be a function mapping
from the states to the set of real
numbers and we'll say action rewards
this is a slight modification to the MDP
formalism where now the reward function
R as a function mapping from States and
actions to D rewards and so you know in
an MDP you stop the mistake
s0 you take an action a zero then based
on value gets s1 take an action a1 to
state s to get to state s to take an
action a 2 and so on and with a state
action rewards the total payoff
there's written like this and this is
this this allows you to model that
different actions may have different
costs for example in the little robot
wandering around the maze example maybe
it's more costly for the robot to move
than to stay still
and so if you have an action for the
robot to stay still the reward can be
you know zero for staying slow and a
slight negative reward for moving
because you're burning or because
because you're using electricity and so
in that case
Velma's equations becomes this v-star
equals where now you still break down
the value of a state as a sum of the
immediate reward
plus the you know expected future
rewards but now the immediate or what
you get depends on the action that you
take in the current state right so this
is a and so this is Bellman's equations
and if and notice that previously you
know we had the max kind of over here
but now you need to choose the option a
that maximizes you immediate reward plus
your discounted future rewards which is
why the max kind of moved right if your
local equation you look at this equation
I guess the Mac set to move outside
because now the immediate reward you get
depends on the action you choose at this
step in time as well this models that
different actions may have different
costs yeah
oh yes yes yes just max applies to the
entire expression right yeah let's see
so in this formulation ever wasn't
deterministic based on the state and
action yes that is correct
so in this formulation the reward
depends on the current state and the
current action but all on the next date
you get two okay oh and by the way there
are multiple variations of formulations
of MVPs but this is some one convenient
one I guess the model that different
costs and I think and and action and
you're finding a helicopter a common
formulation of this would be to say that
yanking aggressively on the control
statements should be assigned a higher
cost because yanking the control stick
aggressively causes a helicopter to jerk
around more and so maybe you want to
penalize that by setting reward function
that you know penalizes very aggressive
maneuvers so these are ways that this
gives you the as a problem designer sort
of more flexibility right and then and
then finally so I'm gonna just write
this on top in this formulation the
optimal action so right so in order to
compute the value function you can still
use value iteration right which is snow
you know V of s just updated as
basically the right-hand side from
pellman's equations so now the iteration
works just fine for the state action
reward formulation as well and if you
apply value iteration until the
convergence of esau then the optimal
action is just the opposite
right so soap I saw is just the odd max
of this thing right now when you're
given state you want to choose the
action that maximizes your media reward
plus your expected future rewards okay
so I think just maybe another example if
you want to use an MDP to planner
shortest route for robot say drive from
here in Stanford to drive up to San
Francisco right then if it costs
different amounts to drive on different
Road segments because they're traffic or
because of the speed limit on different
roads then this allows you to say that
while driving this distance on this road
cost this much in terms of fuel
consumption or in terms of time and so
on so
or in factory maintenance if you send in
a team to maintain the machine that has
a certain cost versus if you do nothing
that has a different cost but then the
machine breaks down it has yet another
cost evaluations okay so that's the
first generation the second generation
is the finite horizon
MDP and in a final horizon MDP we're
going to replace the discount factor
gamma with a horizon time she and and
we'll just forget about the discount
factor and in the final horizon
MDP the MDP will run for a finite number
of t step so you stopping to state a
zero take an action a zero get to s1
take action a one get to state st take
an action a T at time step T and in the
world ends and it we're done right and
so the payoff is this finite sum and and
kinda it's just a full stop at the end
of that um you can also apply
discounting but usually when you have a
finite horizon MDP maybe there's no need
to apply discounting and so this model
is a problem where there are you know T
time steps and then the world ends after
that right or what world end sounds a
bit dire but you know if you find an
airplane or if I hold copter and you
know you only have fuel you know for 30
minutes right RC helicopter whatsoever
have 20 30 minutes of fuel then you know
that you're gonna run this thing for 30
minutes and then you're done and so the
goal is to accumulate as many rewards as
possible up until you you know run out
of fuel and then you have
laughs right so that be example of a
finer horizon MDP now and and and ago is
to maximize this payoff or the expected
payoff over these tea time steps okay
now one interesting property of a finite
horizon of a fine horizon MDP is that
the action you take may depend on what
time it is on the clock right so there's
a clock marching from you know x at 0 to
x at t whereupon right the world ends
the way whereupon that's all the rewards
the MDP is trying to collect and one
interesting effect of this is that this
pendulum right is that the optimal
action may depend on what what the time
is on the clock so let's say your robot
is running around this maze and there's
a small plus one reward here and much
larger +10 reward there and let's say
your robots is here right then the
optimal action for whether you go left
or go right will depend on how much time
you have left on the clock if you have
only you know two or three times as left
on the clock it's better to just rush
and get the plus one but we still have
you know 10 20 ticks left on the clock
then you should just go and get the plus
tender one and so in this example pi
star of s it's not well-defined because
well the the optimal action to take when
you robot is here in this station you go
left watch it you're right
it actually depends on what time it is
on the clock and so PI star in this
example should be written instead PI
star subscript T of s because the auto
action depends on what time T it is the
technical term for this is that this is
a non-stationary
non stationary policy and non stationary
means it depends on the time actually
changes over time right whereas in
contrast up until now we've been saying
you know PI star of s is the octal
policy before we before this formalism
right which is at PI star of s and
that's was a stationary policy and
stationary means or does not change over
time okay so one one one thing that dumb
I didn't quite prove but that was
implicit was that the optimal action you
take in the original formulation is the
same action right no matter what time it
is in the MDP so in the original
formulation that you saw last week the
octal policy was stationary meaning that
the optimal policy is the same policy no
matter what time it is it doesn't change
over time
whereas in fine horizon MDP setting the
Austral policy you know the also action
changes over time and so this is a non
stationary policy so say XI versus on
stage she just means does it change over
time or does it not change over time
okay
and so if you're using a non stationary
policy anyway you can also build an MDP
with non stationary the transition
probabilities one on stage three rewards
actually so maybe here's an example um
let's say you're driving from campus
from Palo Alto to San Francisco and we
know that rush R is that what like 5
p.m. or 6 p.m. or something right and
maybe maybe the weather forecast even
says it's gonna rain at 6 p.m. or
something right but so you know that the
dynamics of how you drive your car from
here at the San Francisco will change
over time
as in the time it takes you know to
drive on a certain segment of the road
is a function of time and if you want to
build an MDP to solve the best way to
drive from here in San Francisco say
then the state transitions so SC plus
one is drawn from state transition
probabilities indexed by the state at
time T and the action at time T and if
these state transition probabilities
change over time then if you index it by
the time T this would be an example of a
non-stationary of a non stationary state
transition probabilities okay or
alternatively if you want non stationary
rewards then you can have a superscript
T of si is the reward you get for taking
a certain action for being at a certain
state at a certain time okay so all of
these are different variations of MDPs
and so maybe just a few examples of when
you will want a final horizon MVP or use
a non stationary state transitions so
let's see if you are flying an airplane
right for some airplanes something like
for commercial very large commercial
airplanes sometimes over a third of the
weight of the airplane comes from the
field right so actually if you take a
large commercial airplane you know when
you take off from SFO and you fly - oh
no way you guys prefer to fly - I
applied to London or something it's very
direct flex appears in London by the
time the plane lands and get much
lighter airplane than when you took off
because maybe sometimes maybe like a
third of the weight disappear you know
because of burning fuel and so then the
dynamics there how an airplane feels
between takeoff and landing is actually
different because the weight is
dramatically different and so this would
be one example of where the state
transition priorities changes and a
pretty predictable way right
or oh right already mentioned weather
forecasts right where weather forecasts
of traffic for cars would be driving
here or drive yeah if you're driving
over different types of terrain over
time you know that's gonna rain tomorrow
you're gonna know it's gonna rain
tonight and the ground will turn muddy
you know then all the traffic would turn
bad and then on the industrial
automation um I'll see how friends work
on industrial automation and I think
that may be one example if you run a
factory 24 hours a day then the cost of
labor you know getting people to come
into the factory to do some work at noon
is actually easier right and less costly
than getting someone to show up in the
factory to do some work at 3:00 a.m.
right and so depending on really labor
availability over time the cost of
taking different actions and the cost of
and and the likelihood of transitioning
to different stations and priorities can
vary over the 24 hour clock as well
right so these are other examples of
when you can have a non safety policy
and non safety state transitions okay
now um let's talk about how you would
actually solve for a fine horizon MDP
and I think for the sake of simplicity
for the most part I'm going to not
bother with non stations transition
rewards so for the most part just focus
on for the most part it's gonna forget
about you know the fact that this could
be beer being I mentioned it briefly but
I want to focus on the finer horizon
aspect
so so let me define the autovalue
function
so this is the also value function for
time T for starting a new state as so
this is the expected total payoff
starting in state s at time T and if you
execute you know the best possible
policy so now the optimal value function
depends on what time it is because if
you look at that example with the +1
reward on the left and the +10 reward on
the right depending on how much time you
have left on the clock the amount of
rewards you can accumulate can be quite
different if you have more time yet more
than you know you can more time to get
to the past and reward indeed and the +1
and +10 rewards that I drew example that
you just now and so um in this example
value iteration becomes the following it
actually becomes a dynamic programming
algorithm what you see in a second ok
which is that
all right which is that the star of T of
S is equal to max' over a R of the s a
plus and actually this is a question for
you so this does this one missing thing
here right so what's saying that the
optimal value you can get when you start
up in state as at time T is the max over
all actions of the immediate reward plus
sum of s prime state transmitter is s
prime times V star of s prime and then
what should go in that box okay cool
awesome great right and then PI star of
s is just you know off max of 80 right
of the same thing of this whole
expression up on top and so this formula
defines VT as a function of V T plus 1
so this is like oh this is like the
iterative step right given meet engine
compute V now I'm given V now you can
abbreviate given behavior music v7 and
so to start this off there's just one
last thing we need to define which is
the capital T at the finite step at the
final step when the clocks about to run
out all you get to do is choose the
action a
that maximizes the immediate reward and
then and then and then there's no sum
after that right so if you start off at
state as at the final time step T then
you get to take an action and you get
immediate reward and then there is no
next day because the world just ends
right after that step which is why the
auto value at time T is just max over a
at the immediate reward because what
happens after that doesn't matter okay
so this is a dynamic programming
algorithm in which this algorithm does
step on top defines you allows you to
compute V saw of T and then the
inductive step or the n plus 1 step I
guess is if you then having computed V
Star of T for every state s right so you
know so you compute this for every state
that's having done this you can then
compute V star t minus 1 using this
inductive step then it's not t minus 2
and so on down to V star of 0 so you
compute this for every state and then
based on these you can compute no sorry
it's PI star of T right compute the auto
policy the non stationary policy for
every states as function of both the
state ok and and I think again I don't
want to draw on this but if you want to
work with non stationary state
transition probabilities or non
stationary rewards then this algorithm
hardly changes in that you can just add
you know if your rewards the state
transceiver is at index by time as well
then this is just a very small
modification to this algorithm and it
turns out that once you're using a
finite horizon
MDP making the rewards and state
transmitters non stationary it's just a
small tweak right so
okay okay
this one Oh an on station so in the end
you get a policy PI star subscript T of
s I'm sorry oke this one oh this one
OSE sure yes Oh a price on this is a
non-stationary policy yes so that's
Island yeah yeah so this the the auto
policy will be an on station policy yes
I think yes I think I was using PI
started not not to denote that it has to
be a fictional target yes that's an
awesome awesome thank you right if you
think big teeth and Finity can just
become the usual value iteration so the
everything so the two things with that
so the two frameworks are closely
related right you can consideration ship
between the valuation um
one problem with taking the strain were
too big t to infinity is that the values
become unbounded right as in yeah well
and that's actually one of the reasons
why we use a discount factor when you
have an infinite horizon MVP when their
interviews goes on forever one of the
things that discount factor does is it
make sure that the value function
doesn't draw without bound
right and in fact you know if the
rewards are bounded by on right by some
R max then when you use discounting then
V you know is bounded by I guess R max
over 1 minus gab
there's someone with dramatic sequence
Oh and so but but when you find her as
entropy because you only add up tira was
it it can't get bigger than T times R
max oh let me think so I think they're
dumb boy so I think you know what you
find is that um let's see
actually let me just draw a one Dedra
just to make life simpler right so let's
see there's a plus one reward there the
plus one reward there if you look at the
optimal value function depending on what
time it is if you have two times and
that's let's say the dynamics are
deterministic right so there's no noise
then if you're two time steps left then
I guess V star would be you know ten ten
ten one one one zero zero right and so
depending on where you are I guess if
you're yeah actually in fact I guess if
you're here there's nothing you can do
right this kind of gets either reward in
time but depending on whether you're
here or here or here at the auto action
will will change you to computer this pi
star this make sense okay yeah maybe do
do cars here there
if this yeah if you actually built a
little you know grid simulator and use
these equations to compute PI sine V
star you will see that the Ottoman
policy when you have lots of time will
be this wherever you are go for the ten
rewards but when the clock runs down if
then the also policy will
end up being a mix-up go left and go
right all right cool all right
so
so the last thing I want to share of you
today is the new quadratic regulation
and as a saying at the start
um lqr applies only in the relatively
small set of problems but whenever the
plies this is a great out room and I
just you know use it whenever right it
seems usable to apply because it is very
efficient and sometimes gives very good
control policies and let's see
and so lqr applies in the following
setting so let's see in order to specify
an MDP we need to specify the state
reactions the state transition or movies
I'm going to use to find a horizon
formulation so capital T and rewards
this this also works with the discounted
MVP formalism but this would be a little
bit easier a little bit more convenient
to develop we've defined a horizon
setting so let me just use that today
and lqr applies under a specific set of
circumstances which is that this set of
states there's an RN set of actions is
in Rd and so to specify the state
transition probabilities we need to tell
you what's the distribution of the
Knicks a given the previous state so to
specify the state transition
probabilities I'm going to say that the
way st plus one evolves is going to be
as a linear function some matrix a times
s T plus some matrix B times a T plus
some noise and sorry there's a little
bit of notation over loading key and
sorry about that a is both the set of
actions as was this matrix a right so
there's two separate things but same
symbol I think I think that the field of
all the ideas of lqr came from
traditional control
from what from mom I guess from EE a
mechanical engineering a lot of their
ideas of reinforcement learning came
from computer science so these two
literature's kind of evolved and then
when the literature's merge you end up
with clashing notation so CS people use
a to denote the set of actions and the
stuff you know mechanical engineering
and EE people use a to denote this
matrix and when we merge these two
literature's the notation ends up being
overloaded okay oh and then um it turns
out one thing we'll see later is that
this noise term it we'll see you later
is actually not super important but for
now let's just assume that the noise
term is distributed Gaussian with some
mean zero and some covariance Sigma
subscript W okay but we'll see later
that the noise will be less important
than you think
right
and so this matrix a is going to you are
n by n and this matrix B is going to be
R and body D where N and D are
respectively the dimensions of the state
space in the dimension of the action
space so for driving a car for example
we saw last time that maybe the state
space is six dimensional so if you're
driving a car I mean the state space is
XY theta x dot y dot beta dot and the
action space is you know steering
control so maybe a is two-dimensional
right acceleration and steering okay so
let's see so to specify an MDP we need
to specify this five tuple right so we
specify three of the elements the fourth
one T is just some number right so
that's easy
and then the final assumption we need to
apply out your arm is that the reward
function has the following form
the reward is negative of s
transpose u s plus a transpose VA where
you yes and by n V is d by D and UV are
a positive semi-definite okay so these
are matrices a and bringing the zeros or
pauses immunity so the fact that U and V
are positive semi-definite that implies
that s T u s is greater than equal to 0
and s transpose u s sorry a transpose VA
is also greater than or equal to 0 so
here's one example if you want to fly an
autonomous helicopter and if you want
you know the state the state vector to
be close to zero so the state vector
captures a position orientation velocity
angular velocity if you want a
helicopter to just hover in place then
maybe you want the state to be you know
regulated or to be controlled near some
zero position and so if you choose u
equals the identity matrix and V also
equal to the identity matrix this will
be different dimensions right this would
be an N by n identity matrix as you add
D by D domain and D matrix then R of sa
ends up equal to negative normal for s
squared plus normal a squared
and so this allows you to this allows
you to specify reward function that
penalizes you know with a quadratic cost
function the state deviating from zero
or if you want the actions deviating
from zero that's penalizing very large
jerky motions on the control sticks or
we said V equal to zero then the second
term goes away okay so these are some of
the cost functions you can specify in
terms of a quadratic cost function okay
now again you know just so that you can
see the generalization if you want
non-stationary dynamics this model is
quite simple to change where you can say
the matrices a and B depends on the time
T you can also say these mean you know
the matrices u and V depends on the time
T so if you have non stationary state
transition probabilities or non
stationary cost function that's how you
would modify this but I won't
I won't use this generalization for
today now
so the two key assumptions of the lqr
framework are that first the state
transition dynamics the way your sales
change is as a linear function of the
previous state and action plus some
noise and second that the reward
function is a quadratic cost function
right so these are the two key
assumptions and so first you know we're
worth where do you get the matrices a
and B one thing that we talked about on
Wednesday already was so again this will
actually work if you're trying to apply
lqr to find the homicidal confidence
this will work for a helicopter flying
at low speeds which is if you find a
helicopter around you know start to some
state as zero take an action a zero get
to state s1 do this until you get to st
right and then this was the first trial
and then you do this M times so we
talked about this on Wednesday so fly
the helicopter through M trajectory sort
of T time steps each and then we know
that we want st plus 1 is approximately
ast plus PA t and so you can minimize
right so we want the left in the right
hand side to be close each other so you
could you know minimize the squared
difference between the left hand side
and the right hand side in a procedure a
lot like linear regression in order to
fit matrices a and B so if you actually
fly a helicopter around and collect this
type of data and fit this model to it
this will work you know this is actually
a pretty reasonable model for the
dynamics of a helicopter and those
speeds okay so this is one way to do
so let's see method one is to learn it
right a second method is to linearize a
nonlinear model so um let me just
describe the ideas at a high level
which is let's say that and I think for
this it might be useful to think of the
inverted pendulum right so that was uh
you know say imagine you've uh yeah
inverted pendulum that was that Rangi of
a pole you're trying to your long
vertical pole you try to keep it
balanced so for an inverted pendulum
like this
if you download an open source physics
simulator or if you have a friend you
know from from the physics degree help
you derived in Newtonian mechanics
equations for this let's see I actually
tried to work through the physics
equations or inverted pendulum ones is
pretty complicated but you might have a
function that tells you that if the
state is a certain position orientation
of the pole lost the angular velocity
and you was it apply a certain
acceleration the options are certainly
left for settling right then you know
one tenth of a second later the state
will get to this right so you you know
your physics friend can help you derive
this equation and and and then maybe
plus noise right well no just ignore the
noise for now and so what you have is a
function
right the maps from the state xx dot
theta theta dot that's a position of the
cart and the angle of the pole and the
velocities and angular velocities
they're maps from the current state at
time t excuse me comma 80 right maps
from the I guess current state vector to
the next state vector as a function they
comments a nuclear reaction okay so um
yes what Vineyards asian means and i'm
going to use a 1d example so because i
can only draw on a flat board right i
can't do because because of the two
dimensional nature of the white board
I'm just gonna use a let's let's suppose
that do you have SC plus one equals f of
s T and let me just forget let me just
ignore the action for now so I have one
input and one output so I can draw this
more easy on the white board so if you
have some function like this so the
x-axis is s T and Y axis is SC plus one
and this is the function f right well
plug in back the action later what the
linearization process does is you pick a
point I'm gonna call this point st over
bar and we're going to
you know take the derivative of F and
finish straight lines are you annoyed
really not very well take the tangent
straight line at this point s T bar and
what and we're going to use this
straight line and we're going to use the
green straight line to approximate the
function okay and so if you look at the
equation for the green straight line the
green straight line is a function
mapping from st 2sc plus 1 and s bar is
the point around which your linearizing
the function so s bar is a constant and
this function is actually defined by SC
plus 1 is approximately the derivative
of the function at s Bar times st minus
s bar plus s Bar T ok and so so s bar T
is a constant and this equation
expresses s T plus 1 as a linear
function of s T so think of it as
volunteers a fixed number right it
doesn't vary so given some fixed s bar
this equation here this is actually the
equation of the green straight line
which is it says you know if you've used
the green straight line to approximate
the function f this tells you what is s
T plus 1 as a function of s T and this
is a linear and affine relationship
between s T plus 1 ok so that's how you
will linearize a function and and in a
more general case where and in a more
general case where SC plus 1 is actually
a function of you know putting this back
again right both st and a t the formula
becomes well i'll write out the form in
a second effect on in this example s bar
T is usually chosen to be a typical
value for s and so in particular if you
expect your helicopter to be doing a
pretty good job hovering near the stage
0 then it'd be pretty reasonable to
choose s Bar T to be the vector of all
zeros because if you look at how good is
the green line as an approximation of
the blue line right in a small region
like this you know the green line is
actually pretty close to the blue line
and so if you choose as bar to be the
place where you expect your helicopter
to spend most of its time then the green
line is not too bad an approximation so
the true function to the physics OC you
know if you expect for the inverted
pendulum if you expect that your
inverted pendulum will spend most of its
time but the pole upright and the
velocity not too large then you choose s
bar to be maybe the zero vector and so
long as your pendulum your inverted
pendulum is spending most of its time
kind of you know close to the zero state
then the green lines not too bad an
approximation for the blue line right so
this is an approximation but you try to
choose them because I mean in in this
little region it's actually not that bad
an approximation is only when you go
really far away right that there's a
huge gap between the linear
approximation and the true function
okay and so in the more general case
where f is a function about the state
and the action then what you have to do
is the input now becomes st comma 80
because f maps from st comma 82 st plus
1 and then instead of choosing as bhatia
choosing as bar t comma a bar T which is
a typical state in action around which
you linearize the function let me just
write down the formula for that
in which you would say if you linearize
around the points given by s party a
body under the typical values then the
form that you have is st plus 1 is given
by f of s bar ta bar t plus the gradient
with respect to s so this is the
generalization of the 1d function we
measure just now we wrote down just now
which says that you know the next day
there's approximately this point around
you which you linearize plus the
gradient respect to s times how much the
state differs from the linearization
point plus the gradient respect the
actions times how much the action vary
from a bar and this kind of generalizes
that equation you wrote
so so this equation expresses as T plus
1 as a linear function or technically an
affine function of the previous state
and previous action right well some
matrices in between and from this you
know after some algebraic mundane you
can re-express this as st plus 1 equals
a st plus ba t and and just that there
is just one other little detail which is
you might need to redefine st to add an
intercept term right and because this is
a affine function with a intercept term
rather than the linear function but so
from this formula you know with a little
bit of algebraic Montaigne you should
really figure out whether the matrices a
and B but you might need to add an
instep term to the s but is just an
affine function you can rewrite in terms
of nature's the same ok um alright so I
hope that makes sense right that this
thing this linearization thing expresses
St plus 1 as a linear function of s tnat
right this is just a linear system the
way st plus one varies you know it's
just a matrix i'm st some matrix times
80 and that's why was someone jean you
can get into this form there for some
matrix a ok but because there are some
constants floating around as well like
this you might need an extra interceptor
to multiply into a to give you that
extra constant
but where we are we now have that for
these MVPs either by learning a linear
model with the matrices a and B or by
taking a nonlinear model and linearizing
it like you just saw you can model
hopefully more than MVP as a linear
dynamical system meaning this you know
st plus 1 is this linear function or the
previous state in action as well as
hopefully with a quadratic reward
function or they really write in the
form that we saw just now so let me just
summarize the problem we want to solve
AST sorry
st plus 1 equals a st plus ba t + WT so
this is a noise term and then our s a
equals negative s transpose you have a
transpose and this is a fine horizon MDP
so the total payoff is a R of s 0 ok
so let's take other dynamic programming
algorithm for this the remarkable
problem that the remarkable property of
lqr and what makes this so useful is
that if you are willing to model your
MVP using those sets of equations then
the value function is a quadratic
function right and so let me show you
what I mean and so if your if your model
if your MVP can be modeled as this type
of linear dynamical system with a
quadratic cost function then it turns
out that V Star is a quadratic function
and so you can compute V star exactly
right so let me show you what I mean
we're going to develop a dynamic
programming algorithm to compute the
optimal value function V star similar to
what we did you know below earlier today
with the final horizon MDP with a finite
set of states this starts with the final
time step and it will work backwards so
V star T of s T is equal to max' over 80
of R of s T 80 this is max over 80 of
negative
right but this is always greater than or
equal to 0 because V is positive
semi-definite and so the optimal action
is actually they just choose the action
zero and so the max over this is equal
to negative st transpose u st right
because uh because v is a positive semi
definite matrix this thing is always
greater than zero and then and so this
tells us also that pi star the final
action is the arc max so the auto action
is to choose you know the vector of zero
actions at the last time step okay so
this is the base case for the dynamic
programming step of value duration where
the optimal value at the last time step
is just choose the action that maximizes
the immediate reward which means
maximize this right and this is
maximized by choosing the action zero at
the last time step okay no
now the key step to the dynamic program
implementation is the following which is
um suppose that V star T plus 1 st plus
1 is equal to a quadratic function so
indeed
yes it's true that this term is also
driven to zero without the minus sign
right what about the minus I that term
is positive and so but you only get to
maximize respect to eighty right so so
the best you could do for this term the
cell is zero thank you all right now for
the inductive case we want to go from VT
plus one we saw three plus one to
computing beats 13 and the key
observation that makes lqr work is let's
suppose V star T plus one the auto value
function at the next time step let's
suppose it's a quadratic function so
particularly suppose V star T plus one
is you know this quadratic function
parameterize by some matrix this capital
Phi T plus one which is an enviable n
matrix and some constant offsets I which
is a real number
um what we'll be able to show is that if
you do one step of dynamic programming
if this is true for V star T plus 1 that
V T after one step as you go from V
salty cylinder V T that the optimum
value function VT is also going to be a
quadratic function with a very similar
form right look I guess T plus one
replaced by T alright and so in the
dynamic programming step we are going to
update VT s T equals max of eighty R of
s C comma 80 plus and then you know I
think you remember when I previously
writers previously we had some over s
prime Oh actually St plus 1 I guess the
s T 18
SC plus one B star c plus 1 St plus 1 so
that's what we had previously when we
had a discrete state space and was
summing over it but now that we have a
continuous state space this formula
becomes expected value with respect to s
T plus 1 drawn from the state transition
probabilities B star pieces 1 so the
optimal value when the clock is a time T
is choose the action a the maximizes the
immediate reward plus the expected value
of you know your future rewards when the
clock has now ticked from time T to time
T plus 1 in your in state as t plus 1 at
time t plus 1 so let's see so this is a
pretty beefy piece of algebra to do I
think I feel like showing this full
result is oh no it's like at the love of
complexity of a you know typical CS 229
homework problem which is quite hard but
let me just show the outline of how you
do this derivation and why you know why
this inductive step works right but I
think you but but if you want you could
work through the algebra details
yourself at home which is that
so be sautee of s T is equal to max'
over 80 of the immediate reward right so
that's the immediate reward and then
plus the expected value with respect to
s T plus one is drawn from a Gaussian
would mean a st plus ba t and covariance
Sigma W so remember s T plus 1 is equal
to ast plus ba t + WT where WT is
Gaussian with mean 0 and covariance
Sigma W right so if you choose an action
a T then this is the distribution of the
next state at time T plus 1 and then
expected value of this quadratic term
because this quadratic term here I kind
of in the inductive case was what we
showed was V star for the for the next
time step right so it turns out that
let's see so this is a quadratic
function and this expectation is the
expected value of a quadratic function
with respect to s drawn from the
Gaussian right well the certain mean a
certain variance so it turns out that
the expected value of this thing well
this whole thing that I just circled
this thing simplifies into a big
quadratic function
of the action 80 and then and so in
order to you know derive the odd max of
the derive V stylus you would derive
this big quadratic function take
derivatives with respect to a tea set to
0 right and solve for a tea and if you
go through all that algebra then you
actually then you end up with the
formula for a tea as follows
okay and I'm gonna use I'm gonna I'm
gonna take that big matrix and don't
know that Lt okay oh and so this shows
also that PI star at time T of s T is
equal to L T times s T so one the
takeaway from this is that under the
assumptions we have rather than the
dynamical systems a quadratic cost
function the octo action there's a
linear function of the state s T right
and this is not a claim that is made
through function approximation what did
I'm not saying that you can fit a
straight line to the Osmo action and if
you fit a straight line that you get
this linear function right that's not
what we're saying we're saying that of
all the functions any way I could
possibly come up with in the world
linear or nonlinear the best function
the best option is linear so there is no
approximation here right so it's just
that you know it's just a fact that if
you have linear dynamical system the
best possible action at any state is
going to be a linear function of that
state right so there's notice that we
have an approximate or anything right
let me let me let me write this here and
then the other step is that if you take
the autumn action and plug it into the
definition of V star then by simplifying
Michigan is quite a lot of algebra but
after simplifying you end up with this
equation where again I just write out
the formulas
okay
all right
so to summarize the whole algorithm
right this let's put everything together
oh and so sorry and so what these two
equations do is they allow you to go
from B star t plus 1 which is defined in
terms of 5t plus 1 and side t plus 1 and
it allows you to recursively go back to
figure out what is V star T using these
two equations right so Phi T depends on
Phi T plus 1 sy T depends on Phi T plus
1 inside p plus 1 and this Sigma W this
is the covariance of WT right there's
the Sigma subscript of you this is not a
summation over W is a Sigma matrix
subscript 2 by W that was the covariance
matrix for the noise terms we were
adding on every step you know linear
dynamical system okay and there's a
trace operator some of the diagonals ok
so just to summarize here's the
algorithm you will initialize Phi T to
be equal to negative u and side T equals
0 and so you know that's just taking
this equation and map here there right
so the final time step that those two oh
sorry
should be capital T so that those two
equations to fire inside it defines V
star of capital T and then you would you
know recur circle let me calculate Phi T
and sy t using Phi T plus 1 si T plus 1
so you go from you know but t equals t
minus 1 t minus 2 and so on and go
backward calm down from right t minus 1
t minus 2 and so on down to 0 calculate
L T as above right then LT was a formula
I guess we had over there saying how the
optimal action is a function of the
current state depending on the a and B
and Phi and then finally PI star of s T
equals L T of s T ok and this algorithm
the remarkable thing one really cool
thing about lqr is that there is no
approximation anywhere right you you
might need to make some approximation
steps in order to approximate a
helicopter as a linear dynamical system
by you know fitting matrices a and B the
data or by taking a nonlinear thing and
linearizing it and you might need to
just restrict constrict you knee
restrict your choice that possibly
reward functions reward function is
called driving but once you've made
those assumptions none of this is
approximately everything is exactly
yes that's right yep yeah so the
approximation step neither are getting
your MDP into the form of a linear
dynamical system will record you have a
reward so that is approximate but once
you specify the MTP like that all of
these calculations were exactly right so
so we're not approximating the value
function of a quadratic function is that
the value function is a quadratic
function and you're computing it exactly
and the also policy is a linear function
and you're just computing computing that
exactly okay I want to mention before
wrap i want to mention one one unusual
fun facts about lqr and this is very
specific to young and and and it's
convenient but but it let me say well
the fact is then just be careful that
this doesn't give it a wrong intuition
just it does imply to anything other
than lqr which is that if you look at
where so first if you look at the
formula for L
all right
even though can the formula LT you need
to compute I mean the you know you the
go up doing all this work is to find the
also policy right so you want to find LT
so you can compute the auto policy you
notice that LT this depends on Phi but
not sigh right so you and and maybe it's
kinda make sense you're going to when
you take an action you get to some new
stage and your future payoffs it's a
quadratic function plus a constant it
doesn't matter what that constant is
right and so in order to compute the
optimal action and all compute e you
need to you need to know Phi or actually
Phi T plus one but you don't need to
know what is sigh t plus one know
if you look at the way we do the dynamic
programming the backwards recursion one
of you can ferment a piece of code that
doesn't bother to compute sigh right so
these are the two equations you use
update fire inside but whatever you know
let's see you delete this line of code
just don't bother the computer and just
don't bother compute that and don't
bother to compute that so you notice
that Phi depends on Phi T plus one but
it doesn't depend on side and so you can
implement the whole thing and compute
the octo policy and completely on also
actions without ever computing sy right
now the funny thing about this is that
the only place that Sigma W appears is
that it affects only citee right so you
know if we do want to just cross out in
our range and just don't bother the
computes I T then the whole algorithm
doesn't even use Sigma W so one very
interesting property of the lqr you know
if this formalism is that the optimal
policy does not depend on Sigma W right
and I think maybe this is a cell V star
depends on Sigma W because if the noise
is very large if they're huge does it
wind blowing helicopter all over the
place then the value would be worse but
PI star and LT do not depend
I'm sigma/w okay um so this is a
property that's very specific to lqr
don't don't don't over generalize it to
other reinforcement learning algorithms
but this I think the intuition to take
from this is first if you're actually
applying the system you know don't
bother to don't don't like so don't
don't try too hard to estimate Sigma W
because you know actually you don't
actually need to use it which is why
when we're fitting a linear model I
didn't talk too much about how you
actually estimate Sigma W because in the
lpr system it literally doesn't matter
in a mathematical sense in terms of what
is the optimal policy you compute and in
a second there may be slightly useful
intuition to take away from this is that
for a lot of MVPs if you're building a
robot you know remember to add some
noise to your system but the exact noise
you add doesn't matter as much as one
might think so what I've seen and then
working a lot of robots a lot of MVPs is
you know do add some noise your system
and make sure your learning algorithm
Israel busting noise and the form of the
noise you add it does matter I don't say
it doesn't matter at all I mean now Kira
doesn't matter all for other MGP as it
does matter but I think the fact that
you remember to add some noise is often
in practice more important than the
exact details of you know is the noise
10% higher distant noise stem cell or if
the noise is a hundred percent higher
lower that will often make the big
difference but but but when I'm you know
training all the were helicopter or
something the noise is something that
you know I pay a little bit attention to
but I pay much more attention to making
sure that the matrices a and B are
accurate and then a little bit
sloppiness in the actress even noise
ball doing something that an MTP could
probably survive then your policy for
survive okay let's take one last
question
Oh V Bo OSE sorry yes see my nose V that
was a this is a beat yes okay cool
thanks everyone
let's break and I will see you for the
final lecture on Wednesday
thanks everyone